oh also yeah thanks for the so many
donations from everyone
to eric rose and clips on youtube
for those with amazon prime thank you
calling roddy
reminding people okay i'm not going to
berserk this game we're gonna have a
slow chill instructive game
i'll still try and address the questions
um i'll play e4 play something
maybe something classical maybe an
italian
oh does black want a stafford
i'm debating i don't know what to do
it's very likely that knight c6 will
come
i could transpose to halloween
i could play bowdoin kizzaritsky i think
i'll play bowdoin kizuritsky
it's a nice kind of active way kind of
fits my style
oh okay so now black doesn't accept the
gambit so now we're back into
some sort of italian i could go for a
fried liver
when i was younger i used to play d4
i think i'll play d3 i'll keep it slow
i'll keep it kind of more positional
strategic
and it's been a while since i played
this uh
italian formation went through a phase
of playing this
a lot of players were playing a4 these
days
hey eric leetsku thanks for the awesome
content
oh thank you for being awesome also yeah
okay thanks again gciba gifting five
subs
thanks colin roddy thank you
blunderprone for the super generous
donation
and gme short seller and sujay x chess
oh got into streaming recently
tips for getting a lot of viewers uh
patience
um it definitely doesn't come overnight
unless you get like a giant rage from
hikaru or xqc
but it's important like if you're
streaming or doing any form of like
content creation that you're
you're doing what you enjoy you're
bringing value to other people
and um if you are providing value then
people will come over time
and that can take a while to build up
build up like a consistent viewer base
i wrote an article for
a chess life magazine back in august
where i've i have a section on kind of
beginner tips and
i'm pretty sure there's there's a pdf
somewhere online
the article command will link to my um
like the cover story that i wrote
a large part of it focuses on like the
twitch chess boom
um
but another part focuses on just like
streaming and being a content creator
okay so i didn't really explain what i
was doing here i was just kind of
gaining space on the king side
sometimes a more exotic idea in these
italian positions
um f6 it maybe could be weakening but
it's probably playable
i'll play queen d2
not sure where my king wants to go
okay now knight f5 looks nice
so hitting the queen
i didn't play 95 earlier because black
train
it's still not easy to crack
i might end up trading
choices choices
there's a lot of things i can take
everything our diagonal things are
staring at each other
i take on b6 knight takes i take here
[Music]
pawn takes it's pretty forcing
i take here queen takes rook g1 rook g8
and maybe i castle and if black castles
i play this and i'm in material
i think though i might maybe i'll take
here first i think the small improvement
there's a small trick if black takes a
bishop
i don't take back but rather take on g7
when material yeah this is not a typical
italian okay so the knight took
it gives me some more options i have the
possibility of maybe taking a knight g5
or taking here first
let's take here first um
because queen takes is most natural
looking but it loses material
because i can take and now if pawn takes
i take here
jaspeed said what is this insanity
pogchamp yeah every game includes some
insanity
let's keep making things insane also i
have two pieces hanging
oh there's a funny line okay so i'll
play knight g5
queen what by dolly parton on amazon
music
what dolly parton
unexpected dolly parton
do people hear this
what is this song
i don't like a dmca alexa stop it
um what was the funny line knight g7
yeah knight g7 funny line because now
if takes i fork and then i fork again
or i win the queen yeah alexa was being
weird earlier during i streamed with
irene
and there is some unexpected music
but then it had a song happy birthday
irene which is
actually kind of sweet
what type of song is this it's happy
birthday irene
wow opponent feared my arrows
um does not take the knight so now i
have a choice between knight
seven e6 and knight five e6
or bishop look at this bishop c7
no bishop c7 king g7 i was thinking like
if the queen takes either thing there's
a fork but
i should probably connect the knights
first
and then take on c7
ooh a b q zac with the arrow bits
always have to keep up the arrows
to earn the arrow bits
so the rook's going to move probably to
c8
and then i'll play this we'll pro oh
rook f8
maybe i'll play this move just for the
lols
like i i've have three all of my minor
pieces are
deep within black's territory
but they're all pretty safe bishop's not
defended but it's not attacked
and now the queen wants to enter
sometimes when you throw a party
you should invite everyone to the party
make sure no one's left out
guys eric is genuinely that's right the
nicest people on the planet oh i think
you helped me a lot when he didn't have
to
hoping everyone can sub one extra month
i'll get the party started
oh thanks again eric reason by this
looks 150.
wait that's multiple 250s that's 27.50
thank you ray
welcome back
also what is this position all i need to
do is check the king once
i'm controlling all the squares i can
potentially retreat to
the question is how do i
i have to invite more people to the
party
i really really appreciate that ray
thanks so much for the kind words
my kind bits inspiring people to sub
captain captain encola and paddy finn
and alder bissi
let's yeah let's um let's bring the
pawns to the party
black's a bit stuck here like the
knights pin the king can't move
queen has no purpose in life
i feel kind of bad thinking about what
black should do
but that makes me happy
yeah i mean the position's resignable
but
it's so it's so beautiful like in terms
of the peace harmony
i kind of want the game to go on like
the party's just getting started
okay so e5
i might just castle why not
everything is under control so i have
time to work with
so many subs yeah dulce peter gifting
five and the stephen gray gifting five
and my knot 3y trash carp taxi five
oh the king found a square okay so i'll
put the
rook aligned with multiple targets
yeah it's um
[Music]
it's so nice when the rook is aligned
with so many um
so many weak points
i don't think the pawn is defendable
[Music]
i'm basically two moves away from mate
ooh jesuba from england
thank you jaciba for the bits
captain encola says stop playing with my
food
but it's so delicious i'm just i'm
savoring the food
[Music]
sometimes food england you absolute
legend
oh thank you jacebo sometimes food is
just an edible toy
red dev also gifting five
okay so the knight actually all the
pieces are
are really playing a role
oh did i miss that
i got kind of excited like overexcited
and it's still okay i'm not going to
take the rook i'm going to focus on
um pressuring the knight and actually
what i want to do is takes
and then take some
um yeah still still some moves away from
me
okay so i've i removed the rook from
defending the knight now i have three
attackers
oh i can fork
too many ways to have fun play this move
i could have taken the knight but um i'm
hoping for a rook f7 here
because it looks logical to defend the
knight
right i have three attackers still the
knights pinned
it's the only way to defend the knight
and a third time
stop pinning yeah the light has been
forever pinned
at least in recent memory
yeah i should know that if we got seven
there's queen f5 mates
um so we'll take and probably go for
we'll go for another
pin type thing or maybe maybe we'll just
go for force mate
um that's what's more efficient here
thanks eric oh this is more efficient
oh there's bots i'm sorry chat
sometimes this will happen um
okay i'm not sometimes
playing chess is more fun than
moderating chat
oh thanks diamond cutter yeah diamond
cutter knows what to do
okay so this is kind of a cool finish
because
queen takes here and then yeah
okay thanks for the game pikachu
pikachu pikachu is like a legend it's a
legendary pokemon
it's also a legendary sub gifter to
moist critical
okay that was a fun game
italian turns into a party basically